Does the point 3, 7 lie on the line y equals 3x minus 5? I'm going to walk you
through some of the steps to do this, or at least give you some hints about how
we should go about it. I'd like you to start by substituting in the proper value
from the point into the left-hand side of the equation. L H S here is just
shorthand for left-hand side. So type in the value here of the number that this
side should simplify to. Then do the same thing for the right-hand side. That's
what R H S stands for. Plug in the proper coordinate to the proper variable, and
simplify this side of the equation. Once you've found the numbers that belong in
these boxes. Tell me if they're equal to one another, and then, depending on how
you answer that question, what does this say about whether or not this point
lies on this line?